it is so good to see things starting to
return to normal and as that happens a
lot of people are thinking
hey maybe i let myself go over the last
year staying at home
access to the pantry time to get in
shape time to lose a little weight
time to lose some fat well there's a way
to do that we're going to talk about
fast fit
technology now doug zuko joins us again
how you doing doug
fantastic thanks for having me i love
having you here we all see
we've seen the amazing success stories
of people who have lost fat
with fast fit but let's talk today about
how what you offer
can improve people's health
well we always talk about the fat loss
technology but we don't talk enough
about
the technology helping reduce
inflammation you know tightening the
skin
just making the person feel better all
over improved circulation
but i don't have to talk about it
because the proof's out there the
canadian journal of respiratory therapy
came out with a study and there's a
whole list of benefits
if you want to put that on the screen
that would be wonderful
yeah we got it up there now but
basically they
talk about it help can help with pain
relief can help with cellulite treatment
body contouring of course lymphedema
reduction
hair growth i need that inflammation
musculoskeletal injuries and like i said
improved microcirculation
cellular metabolism lymphatic drainage
and even can speed up the recovery of
covert
so i'm not saying that this is coming
from the canadian journal of respiratory
therapy
well and in addition to all of that you
and i were talking during the break
there are some psychological benefits to
it as well
absolutely by by reducing inflammation
and losing reducing visceral fat
it's proven that we can improve you know
depression and anxiety get rid of that
stuff right make just
just make it feel better a lot of people
could use that right now all right we
want to hear right now from
one of your clients a testimonial here
and then let's talk about that after we
watch this
hello my name is john i came to fast fit
because
trying to lose weight and i tried
everything
i'm under the sun weight pills i've been
on diets i've been gyms and nothing
worked i see a fast food advertised on
tv
and i figured well i'll give it a shot
this is my last resort
and i came here and it was simply
amazing
uh just come in here just relax and you
just lose the weight
doug let's talk about that a little bit
when he says you just come in and relax
what happens
when you go to fast fit how about that
well by using the light technology it
helps
it helps us burn fat that it becomes
impossible for us to burn
once we get over the age of about 35 and
that's the visceral fat
it activates the receptors now now
john's in his late 60s he lost
36 pounds of pure fat 36 pounds of pure
fat
that's fantastic and over the age of 35
you say so i've got about five years
before i have to worry about this but in
the meantime
a lot of people benefiting from it
absolutely no matter we you know we have
uh children as young as eight come in we
had people as old as 94. we have
professional athletes come in we have
people to come in
they can't hardly walk so every range
love it doug it's always great talking
to you really appreciate your time
well thanks for having me all right for
more information you can visit
fastfitbodysculpting.com or call that
phone number right there
1 800 fast fit the first 20 callers
are going to receive a special offer
fast fit has locations in summerlin
west sahara centennial and henderson las
vegas now will be